histoire pour de la vérité je n'aime pas
quand on parle du mouvement de
l'histoire
je suis peut-être un peu plus âgés que
vous mais en 33 en allemagne on
m'expliquait que je refusais de suivre
le mouvement d'histoire au web aux
soutiens et pendant les années 30 il y
avait trop d'américains d'européens qui
disait que le mouvement de l'histoire
c'était le fascisme national socialiste
après la guerre en 45 le mouvement de
l'histoire c'était le communisme alors
ce sont de mauvais des plaisanteries que
je n'accepte pas volontiers parce que le
mouvement du soir vous ne le connaissez
pas non plus le mouvement de l'histoire
entrantes ont expliqué que c'était
machisme en 45 c'était le communisme
aujourd'hui on a découvert ce qu'est le
communisme alors que nous ne savons pas
ce que c'est que l'avenir
quand je vous dit que je suis contre lui
mon histoire ça ne signifie absolument
rien car vous vous êtes un libéral aux
états unis
je suis convaincu que les libéraux aux
états unis sont en train de gagner avec
l'aide de reggane la bataille
idéologique par accident pendant
quelques années il ya eu une réaction
contre les libéralisme américain
alors vous dites un penny eux que vous
êtes obstiné dans le libéralisme mais en
fait vous allez avec l'intelligentsia
américaine depuis 45 cas l'idéologie
dominante aux etats-unis c'était d'être
libéral c'est uniquement depuis quelques
années à la suite d'un certain nombre
d'accidents qu'il ya eu une réaction
contre le libéralisme est en somme pour
moi pour un libéral européen avoir été
contre la mode intellectuelle sartrienne
communiste c'est pour moi la
démonstration que je suis un vrai
libéral n'est pas du tout contre le
mouvement de l'histoire